citizens of the reject nation if you can
look behind us john tell them where
we're at we're at the prey premiere the
fifth predator movie
and easily the best one since the
original and uh you know what's funny
about this premiere today a movie got
cancelled what movie was that batgirl
but what's still coming out that hasn't
been canceled because it's that good
pray
there we go we've successfully promoted
this movie we don't know who we're gonna
get we're at the end of the line which
means
we're their favorite they're saving the
best for last that's what it means at
these uh press junkets that they they
specifically want us to be best for last
right everyone to warm up you know by
the time they get to us then they're
ready to really rap you know that's why
they put like variety and hollywood
reporter over there because they're like
just uh screw them let them walk past
them they're gonna run past the variety
to get to the real rejects today hold on
i gotta talk to greg and john we got
andrew gordon here to do backup audio
which will not sound as good as this but
andrew say hi what's up citizens of
reject nation we don't know who we're
gonna get
i just hope that we at least get a
background player press junkets are like
a box of chocolates man
it's gonna be good
[Music]
oh really oh that means the world man
you always do red carpets no are you la
local la local yeah yeah yeah we're
getting asked questions my dad tracked
the burrito it's john right there so sad
dude yeah guys we're here with dan
trachtenberg the amazing director of
prey a movie that you guys have told you
guys time and time again love the hell
out of it and i know we talked for a
while on zoom um but there was one thing
i did really want to ask you but we ran
out of time which was the predator
franchises of course had some
interesting journeys along the way and
now beyond easter eggs was there
anything in particular that you took
inspiration from
in the sequels or things you wanted to
make sure you to intentionally like not
go into the pitfalls of
oh good question um you know we have
this this net
ball situation our movie and
that that is
you know born out of
uh you know a weapon that we've seen in
in the sequels so certainly there's that
predator 2 has one of the greatest movie
transitions of all time when you see the
guy screaming and then
you see that it's just in his in the
predator's hand walking away and i
almost put that in this just one of my
favorite things ever really you know i
was
looking at
some of the errors that the movies in my
opinion have made in terms of the
creature design and the way it moves and
really hoping that we could pull off
what was hinted at in the first movie
the way it jumps through trees and all
that stuff making ours feel as ferocious
as as possibly could do you have an
extended cut of this film because i love
the length it's tight but was there ever
an extended version of this the weirdest
thing in the world this movie
really wanted to be 90 some minutes it
the first cut the editor put together
was about 90 minutes the first cut i put
together and showed the studio was about
90 minutes
it's weird i think that's because it's
so so much of it is his action sequence
it ended up that way but yeah it's i'm
proud of it being
a brisk
film yeah it's kind of got that mad max
telling story through action kind of
flare to it you know do you mind if he
gets one question in with you while we
got some time yeah i'll keep it at one
i've got a bunch of curiosities but one
thing i really
appreciated and sort of started to pick
up more and more watching the movie was
just how much you embraced the title
themes of prey and predator and all this
sort of overlapping circles that put
animals characters etc in those
different roles how intentional was that
were you going for that or did that just
kind of happen as you you know found the
story funny enough heard the last
question the script we even pre-vised
used to open the movies to open
on
a fly gets eaten by a fish the fish gets
eaten by the hawk
the hawk gets shot down by human like it
used to always open with that
sort of
hierarchy of the food chain um because
the predator is coming to a planet
looking for what the alpha is and and
you know our our protagonist is trying
to prove herself to be worthy so
i just really always wanted a movie to
dig into the thematic weight that
that creature
um doing a predator movie has you know
yeah i think you did a great job with
that really quick just one other thing
this is obviously like a big roughing it
experience for your cast how much in the
thick of that were you like did you jump
in the mud with everybody or were you
kind of you know removed for rehearsals
and stuff like that no i didn't jump in
the money
short answer no
it's good good i appreciate that thank
you fruits i appreciate it
hi everybody we talked on zoom for like
a few minutes nice to meet you
personally watched all your interviews
but i watched like you're you're like
compilation are you watching it yeah i'm
so curious about what other people said
so i was like oh how did you energy
very well done oh thank you so much we
already absolutely love it thank you for
taking the time to come back also
through the slime
it means a lot but since i already asked
you a couple questions but there's a
couple that i didn't get to ask you
i'm excited let's do let's do it let's
do it
um one thing was that especially when
talking with a lot of people here coming
to the carpet earlier they were talking
so much about their experience working
with jane about capturing a lot more of
the sincerity and authenticity through
the comanche nation what would you say
was some of the things that you learned
the most about the comanche nation that
you got to apply into this film or
takeaway that you want the audiences to
actually have there were so many things
i mean you know learning i think it was
mostly like the differences between
comanche culture and like my culture i
come from lakota dakota and dakota
people i'm enrolled at the four pack
reservation in montana so you know
that's also plains people but obviously
we're not all the same uh different
language different culture different
practices stuff like that so like
learning the things that we shared and
then the things that were different like
for example in the movie they're hunting
a hawk and i was like oh my god what do
you what because we never do that but
she was like no no or or you know we
share things like there's a whistle at
night in the movie and you know that's
like a big thing for both of our
cultures so getting to not just like
learn about it and have conversations
and i mean even like on set jane was
like making outfits for like her
grandkids and like you know she made
like earrings that i've worn during
press so far like that's great that yeah
like that kind of stuff it was just also
like learning things like that that's
just like personal to my life that are
like good to know or good to see or you
know brush up on some skills like that
kind of stuff was just like to me
personally such a gift and then yeah
like getting to put things in the movie
or like brushing our teeth like dan at
one point was like did people brush
their teeth down and we're like of
course we brushed our teeth what are you
talking about and like she literally
like brought out a knife and like made a
toothbrush and she was like stay here
and then that's in the movie and you
know it's not like here everybody i'm
brushing my teeth but it's just a part
of the movie so like that kind of stuff
is like to me so cool oh that is awesome
um my buddy loved the movie too he's
worse than telling me is there any
chance of controlling you just get one
question in with him too yeah absolutely
come on in here john come here awesome
it's lovely to meet you hello nice to
meet you it's great too because when i
watched the movie i literally shouted
chew stick
um but i'm curious i mean you know so
much of this obviously is very cultural
and whatnot but it's also very physical
and i know that you had to do a bunch of
like badass fight
training but also too you're just like
roughing it out in the land for so much
of the movie is that
kind of akin to how you are in general
was it kind of a challenge being so
just outside the whole time and so kind
of immersed in all of the elements i
enjoyed it i grew up like i brought my
dad a set of throwing axes for father's
day like a couple years before this
movie i think or like my i don't know
when sometime before this movie existed
in my life and then this movie happened
and i was like oh my god i've been
practicing
it paid off yeah so like you know not
for nothing so definitely that kind of
stuff like i just grew up like my
parents had a few acres of property and
we had like dirt bikes and dogs and
horses and things like that so like it
definitely felt nice to me to like be
shooting a movie and then i would just
so often forget because you know like
then being outside and interacting with
like the environment and the elements
just becomes like the thing you pay more
attention to and then you're like oh
right well that's how the movie guides
your attention too like every time you
fade back into just being in the camp
you completely forget about predator
stuff in the first place
that was how it felt shooting the movie
i feel like we shot like three different
movies there was like a comanche camp
movie there was like a naru solo journey
movie and then there was like a predator
movie and i was like oh my god this is
better movie
well awesome
thank you so much really appreciate it
dude what's up pleasure pleasure to meet
you in person man i did not realize how
just [ __ ] tall you are yeah yeah
guys we're with dakota the most badass
people ever right here
thank you so much uh last time we were
talking we were talking a lot about your
musical influences
and one thing i was curious about when
you were making this movie
do you listen to a lot of certain songs
to get kind of in the mood to prepare
for certain scenes or anything like that
if so like what songs were they 100 you
know there's some certain scenes in the
uh in the movie without going into too
many spoilers in which topic kind of
expresses some deep emotions uh you know
and so uh there were certainly songs
that i blasted in my ears i remember one
in particular this was a song that it
kind of heard
at a weird time in my life so it kind of
always emotionally brought me back to a
certain place but before this one
particular scene i just put the
headphones in i cranked viva la vida
by uh
was it cold play yeah yeah is that what
it's called
i know what time you're talking about
yeah yeah yeah sorry to get remember but
that that song really uh did a lot for
me along with many other songs but
yeah certainly played a part in would
you say that your character has a pers
if your character had a theme song
what would you say that theme song would
be
oh
man that's a good question
only daddy that'll walk the line by
wayland jennings for sure
that's a great answer this is my buddy
you talking recognizing to the chair
reaction i was wondering yeah yeah
what's up i was wondering could he ask
you a question he's a big fan of the
movie too we absolutely love this man
john why don't you come in here thank
you dakota appreciate your time man
thank you thank you yeah it's lovely
lovely to meet you seriously i watched
the movie last night and i was blown
away and i gotta ask i mean you know are
you an outdoor kind of person or was
this like a really big sort of you know
foray into just roughing it and how much
did you kind of have to practice at you
know the like watching you guys build
that that um the gurney in that one
scene was like so clockwork and things
like that so like what was the process
like for the physical preparation you
know i i loved uh when i still love i
loved going out in the woods as a kid
you know so luckily that aspect of it
was kind of enjoyable for me i really
enjoyed being able to go out like on an
off day and just i'm gonna go sit in the
field on six ago you know that's uh
that's a
res up there just to kind of you know
decompress so i love that part of it you
know i think if i was on a studio lot or
something i would kind of go a little
crazy maybe for that being my first
movie it was a lot of a lot of
preparation a lot of work you know there
was a diet that they put me on to kind
of make sure i look skinny and sinewy
you got the hollywood abs you know yeah
yeah so that was that was like a little
bit of that but man the exercise i don't
mind so much you know so it was fun but
uh different experience for me for sure
for sure was there a particular skill
that you had to pick up that you're
gonna take with you beyond this
experience oh man so one thing that i
really enjoyed uh was shooting the bow
from the horse uh man oh cool dude i
spent a lot of time riding uh and when
we were practicing i would actually
shoot the bow from the horse and that's
it's kind of a wicked experience
whenever we're with all the crew i'm not
allowed to shoot real arrows so the kind
of cgi those in uh which was
disappointing for me but you still want
to hit the target oh thank you bro i
hope so it was fun very appreciate it
hey thank you guys thank you for your
time
it's been more than a pleasure
thank you
i love watching your videos appreciate
that thank you so much we talked uh
briefly uh on the on the zoom interview
during the press junket so it's nice to
see you in person
i'm not a little square
much more lovely in person one thing
that i did want to ask you that i didn't
get a chance to on the zoom park one
part of this film that i was thinking of
when watching it was a part of the
storytelling feels like because i don't
know much about the comanche nation but
it feels like if the predator was
plopped down into the comanche nation
during this time here's how they would
respond how much was the thought process
put into that to provide the
authenticity and do you feel like this
was like the most authentic
representation they would do for this
type of larger-than-life sci-fi story oh
absolutely because for the comanche
nation we have a mythology and in our
mythology there's a monster called pia
muppets and translated from our language
that means big monster and when it's
described it's almost like the predator
this tall big alien monster with small
eyes big arms nails grabs you know is
out at night so
it fits perfectly we just screened it
for the comanche nation and everybody
was thrilled to see to see that and they
were like see the predator could be that
pia muppets and now everybody will be
scaring their kids because the kids will
be like you know you better behave or
else p.m muppets is going to come and
get you and now it's a predator you know
can i ask what was the what was your
emotional reaction to screaming for the
imagination what was your emotional
response to seeing that it was very
emotional for me i'm an enrolled member
of the comanche nation i'm also black
feet so just this is the first time that
our language has ever been in
in a new movie ever an entirety you know
like through the whole movie we have the
whole thing dubbed in comanche which was
an undertaking and then we here let me
just say but also you know just for
native people when this comes out the
world can click that tile and watch it
in the comanche language so this is the
first time that any native language has
been out in a brand new movie ever so
how would you say that being here
tonight celebrating this movie here is
making you feel just to know that all
this is being celebrated and like the
the early word of mouth is so enormously
positive yeah it's like a it's like a
landslide every time i go somewhere and
they're like did you work on prey and
you know what was that like oh it's a
predator we love the predator because he
has such a great fan base so it's a
really great platform to show native
people as real people to not show us as
a sidekick to not show us as a villain
but to show us as a viable real people
that have they love each other these
brother and sister they have conflict
like everybody else you know brothers
and sisters because i know i did and uh
i'm sure most people do so you know it
just shows us more in a real way of life
well you you actually answered my
follow-up questions so thank you my
father
no my my follow-up question was
basically going to be about what would
you hope that people would take away
from this movie because i imagine that
with the movie like prey you're like oh
comanche nation exploitation b-movie but
then it's actually not that it's
actually so much more than that and what
are you hoping people would take away
and you just did that you answered that
for me you say yeah
you're psychic you're very skilled you
have to thank you so much for your time
jane thank you
great cameo too i call you
last night and i caught you over amber
i want to do that to leave a little
trail for my uh for my grandchildren you
know so they can go god that was our
grandma and look well actually i was
riding a horse in the beginning when you
see the two people when nadu's walking
up the thing going to the camp there's
two people on horseback i i'm on the
left riding the horse
i'm everywhere i'm everywhere it's like
we were we were in canada and the
borders were closed i'm everywhere
thank you jay stormy pleasure to meet
man thank you man sonic nice to meet you
nice to meet you thank you
my name is greg we saw this movie and no
[ __ ] [ __ ] love the hell out of it
it was like insanely amazing like we're
big fans of the predator franchise and
this is easily like the best maybe the
best one since the original so yeah but
so i gotta ask when watching this the
camaraderie between the entire cast felt
so sincere and so authentic what went
into building that camaraderie leading
into the filmmaking oh brother man i got
some stories for you yeah let's hear it
let's hear it
kevin starr blanket homeboy
stunt coordinator ending guy right okay
he's cree badass dude man teaching us
how to maneuver tomahawk fighting knife
fighting working with bows we had a four
week boot camp that's the only thing we
[ __ ] did all right we're getting
deadly we're maneuvering we're working
in diamond formation we're learning how
to peel off left and right without even
saying a word we got hand signals we're
like stop
bro yeah
we're moving and and the sign language
we're using is we're trying to connect
it to actual indian sign language that
the comanches used so we're trying to
use a jane of course jaymar did it she
showed us
and she i'm glad we had it i think the
thing what made this film so successful
was the fact that we had
jane a native
woman
who is that tribe who had knowledge of
that who made sure that this film was
able to go far because otherwise if they
did like a pan-indianism right they
would have mixed up concepts of what
tribes were and that wouldn't have made
it as good but the fact that think about
this man
all right one of the scenes opening
credits on the trailer too you see um
harlan he has his arrow pulled back like
this hand over the top there's a reason
for that
all right it's because when you're
riding horseback
and if you knock it on the bottom the
arrow fall out so you knock it on the
top you're moving maneuvering
the boys arrows already in keep on
rolling all right and then we're working
on like holding multiple arrows in our
hands at once and firing i kid you not
kevin taught us how to curve a [ __ ]
arrow bro
curve and arrow
damn so it's all real
yeah yeah and we're doing the lid that's
what made it so real because we're
actually doing the stuff so when it came
time to film
we already knew how to spread out roll
and maneuver man so you like the way how
this story the story is kind of told
that the action you guys kind of bonded
through learning the action together
yeah yeah
and also man we're actually indians too
yeah yeah they didn't do like a
spaghetti western like they used to do
we're actually indians and it's in our
bones it's genetic so would you say a
lot of these skills were they more
fine-tuned or did you actually learn did
you know a lot of this before you
actually did the movie
both my man both
like
growing up on the res i already knew how
to hunt how to maneuver how to be quiet
how to sneak up on something working
with the bow something my dad shot me a
little bit
kevin starr blanken refined it made it
sharp
tomahawk fighting i actually didn't know
i've never talked about it before man
you know but now i'm you know i'm pretty
i'm pretty pretty wicked with it even
with the blade we're working some blade
stuff i had this old
back in uh i was 12 years old jim
harrison karate veteran right yeah went
to cambodia old war veteran badass dude
right worked with chuck norris a little
bit back in the days yeah he's like he's
legit taught me had a knife fight when i
was a kid nice nice yeah so and then i
was like i already know i kind of have
an idea i got some good ideas how to do
this i just rolled on over easy to films
so that's why i have a double tomahawk
man yeah yeah both hands are deadly with
both hands
thank you dude you were [ __ ] badass
did you like that when i jumped up on
that log bro yeah the log was literally
this high
it was like it's not this high that long
was this it looked dangerous as [ __ ]
yeah yeah it was literally this higher
and i was standing there
and i was like oh man i got a box jump
this cuz i got to make these guys look
badass and they're like just maybe crawl
over it and i was like listen
listen listen alright you can maybe
crawl over and i was like listen guys
let me show you some true athleticism
right now what i can do as an actor just
beyond acting some some real warrior
[ __ ] that log was literally this big
[ __ ] shoulder length and the film it
looks smaller but in reality it was
literally i put my hole
it was a standing box jump cleared it
and i was like
man i only got about 10 good jumps in me
after this man and that's the one where
i jump up on the log and i walk over
there's and i'm like
yeah man so you know just yeah that's
what i did man i tried my best it was a
pleasure talking to you dude thank you
so much thank you so much man hey you
definitely have a good day now all right
take care man thank you thank you for
coming back we we saw this movie and um
the only way i can communicate this is
by just having a little bit of swearing
here i [ __ ] love the hell out of this
movie it is so amazing it is so amazing
so many of your scenes with amber have
so much of this like unspoken dialogue
in history what was the relationship
building like with you and amber with
developing these characters there's so
much history without you guys having to
even really talk about it
yeah you know amber and me immediately
clicked okay
um sorry i've got something in my eyes
so just know that i need to cover it
because my eyelash it was watering so
bad thank you thank you thank you he's
my he's my cleanest handler
amber and me immediately hit it off we
didn't really even need the time to sit
and say okay who are you and me and
how's our relationship it was like
i just think you're an amazing human
being and
she's so genuine and we just floated
into it it was really natural between us
so you guys were able to just sort of
feel it out like it was real acting
right yeah
i mean i immediately adored her and
loved her as a mother would
and we had a we just had some really
beautiful
conversations between takes and you know
when we were just hanging out on set and
in calgary because we shot this in
canada and
yeah yeah so i think with indigenous
people we recognize each other and we
just know that you know it's okay we
don't have to talk too much with this
character there was so much of this
history hinted at with the with the
father actually uh being gone was there
any of that backstory that you would
like to have seen be explored a little
bit more that perhaps you did some of
your own homework on prior to making
this movie
um i think for me
i knew the father was gone but all i
thought of is i'm playing father and
mother to my kids and i really have to
be able to
set them on the right path my son
obviously would be you know bringing in
a lot of how we survive you know a lot
of the animals a lot of the the food i
just wanted my daughter to do what i did
which is you know take care of the
female stuff and she just refused to
listen no matter what i mean
i tried so hard to make her
be a normal woman and she just wouldn't
she refused and she became a hero and
she just kicked ass i mean you guys have
wonderful screen presence together my
buddy here he absolutely love it can he
ask you a question too is that fine all
right thank you thank you so much for
your time
you did a really terrific job in the
movie i feel like it can often be sort
of a role to get stuck with playing mom
and whatever but i thought you really
came to life and i was curious you know
i mean obviously this talking to
everybody tonight it seems like this
means a lot to people and there is a lot
of culture alive in the movie was there
anything you had to prepare for or was
it mostly things that you already kind
of brought in from your own personal
experience well i think i am a mother of
two daughters and i think it was just a
very natural relationship with my my
kids on the film with dakota and amber
and we we just we just rolled with it we
didn't prepare with each other we didn't
we didn't even run lines really we just
kind of showed up on set and just
trusted each other and knew that it
would be there we all know
ourselves as indigenous people so and
did you have any like trepidation i mean
like predator movies or exploitation
movies in part and i think it would be
really easy to just lay a skin over it
being like oh look we said it you know
in in the comanche nation ha ha but it
really feels like is an authenticity
to that and i was curious you know
having it pitched to you and finally
signing on you know like how did that
read on the page
i was really happy to have an indigenous
producer on set i thought that really
made a big difference because everything
felt really authentic
having jane
myers there who was comanche so she was
able to speak into things and i thought
that was really important
it's not often that we get to
show such strength in who we are as a
people i'm not comanche i'm cree
but i mean as indigenous people we were
often portrayed as you know
savages or you know
stereotypes and for me this felt really
authentic
it reads that way yeah do you have a
favorite uh i'm gonna crib one of your
questions do you have a favorite of the
predator franchise aside from this one
are you an action horror monster fan i
am not an action horror and i've never
watched the predator i didn't even watch
it to gear up for the film it's more
authentic that way yeah yeah no i'm more
into drama like just acting and good you
know writing and stuff and i'm not an
action person there's so many action
films i have not watched so
that's good that i feel like part of the
benefit of this movie is that that
authenticity really reads like when you
dip away from predator things and just
go into the life in the camp it's like
you really get pulled into all that
stuff so i thought you guys did a
terrific job just realizing all of that
i did not want to watch it specifically
because i didn't want to lean towards
anything from any of the past predators
so i just thought i haven't seen it yet
i'm not going to watch it i'm just going
to save it so it's perfect what was it
what was it like to skin that giant hide
well i've done that a few times
this is just a regular day for you in my
backyard i skin hide
well awesome
appreciate your time thank you for
talking with us
[Music]